這裡是AI101,全網最幽默的AI新聞。
美國原本放行輝達的A1200,讓它有條件賣到中國。
沒想到,真正把A1200卡住的,反而是北京。北京門一關。
華為就趁這個空檔,靠升騰晶片,搶下更多需求。
可是華為自己也卡住了。產能不足,高頻,寬記憶體也短缺。
回頭看美國當初怎麼想,與其完全禁止中國拿到高階晶片,不如有限度開門。
讓中國企業繼續用美國的硬體和軟體
把中國留在美國生態裡
可是這道小門有代價
2026年1月起
H200要先送進美國
做第三方檢測
再出口中國
進美國就得克25%關稅
成本轉嫁不出去
只能揮打自己吞
就算美國放行
晶片還是很難進去
2025年12月
川普宣佈放行
隔年2月起
美國核發少量出貨許可
但北京仍限制銷售
5月路透社說
一顆都還沒交付
到了7月
出貨少到被形容為微不足道
政策這樣反覆
輝達產線也跟著轉
3月初媒體報道
輝達暫停H200
把臺積電產能轉去做Vera Rubin
結果不到兩週
中國訂單出現產線又重啟
就算真的到貨
也不一定進得了大陸
8月
英國金融時報引述消息人士說
字節跳動和騰訊
各收到大約1萬顆H200
但北京希望多數晶片留在大陸以外
像是放在香港
這些卡關最後都反映在匯達財報上
2027財年第二季
資料中心營收890億美元
運往中國的資料中心HOPPER產品
不到其中1%
下一季猜測
乾脆完全沒算中國資料中心運算收入
匯達運往中國的資料中心HOPPER產品
佔該季資料中心營收不到1%
華為就站出來說他贏了
Eric Su表示
照華為掌握的數據
深藤在中國市佔已經超越匯達
不過這是華為自己說的
樣本和底層數據都沒公佈
外部的估算呢
券商Bernstein預測
到2026年底
輝達在中國AI晶片市場
可能掉到約8%
華為則升到約5成
那華為到底靠什麼強調客戶
Eric Hsu承認
晶片可能沒那麼先進
但供應可預期
可能比紙面效能更重要
華為不一定最快
卻把供應確定性當成賣點
但不會斷貨
不代表供得出來
Eric Hsu也承認華為產能
連中國國內需求都不夠
高頻寬記憶體又短缺
一款生騰晶片
從年初大約6萬人民幣
漲到超過8萬
產能已經不夠
偏偏又有一個大計劃
媒體報道
DeepSeek計劃部署
至少16萬顆生騰950D體
華為2026年
卻可能只產20萬到30萬顆
若數字都成立
會吃掉一半到八成
不過這是匿名消息
兩家都沒證實
比較確定的變化
在軟體
9月30日
DeepSeek在GitHub
公開了支援生騰的開源工具
中國的AI推論
正往華為搬
但大型模型的預訓鏈
還沒有全面離開輝達
所以這場競爭
沒有簡單的贏家
勝負要看三件事
香港的H200
能不能進大陸
華為能不能擴大晶片和記憶體供應
還有中國一線AI公司
會不會連預訓鏈也辦到生騰
追蹤AI101
不錯過AI圈的最新消息